invité de 5 à 10 ce matin marie hélène
lee auteur vous êtes conseillère
exécutive chargée de la culture bonjour
marie hélène les hôtes un bon jour alain
livory bonjour à toute vente unique une
réaction à la mort de johnny hallyday
bien sûr c'est un géant
c'est une légende du showbiz du rock
français qui a acquis qui parti quel que
soit ce que dit ou du personnage il faut
saluer il faut saluer l'artiste une
chanson vous à voir que dès que je
t'aime bien sûr bientôt trois ans à la
tête de la collectivité territoriale et
on peine à voir à comprendre à discerner
vos actions votre politique culturelle à
la martinique alors là on va essayer de
la comprendre
déjà qu'elle est ce qu'il ya une
politique culturelle globale pour la
martinique est forcément qu'à une
martinique et je vais m'arrêter
également sur un événement immédiat
aujourd'hui c'est le 6 décembre il y a
cinq en six ans le 6 décembre 1961 un
grand martiniquais nous laissait il
faudra dommage aussi à frantz fanon
ça fait partie de la politique
culturelle de la 7e et je voudrais
profiter de l'occasion pour tuer dans
l'oeuf une polémique qui commence à se
développer sous les réseaux sociaux
concernant la bibliothèque schoelcher
il y a quelques semaines la bibliothèque
schoelcher comme elle a l'habitude de le
faire reçoit des écrivaines elle a reçu
un écrivain martiniquais qui s'appelle
raphaël confiant qui présentait son
livre franz fanon l'insurrection de
l'âme est justement ce mot hamla est
très important que je vais parler des
orientations de la politique culturelle
de la cité m et comme le personnel a
l'habitude de faire une semaine avant
ils ont fait une vitrine où il
présentait les livres les oeuvres les
ouvrages de raphaël confiant il y avait
un ouvrage qui s'appelait aimé césaire
une traversée paradoxale du siècle je ne
vois pas en quoi le mot paradoxal
traversée paradoxal je vois pas ce que
ça a des sultans du million ou de
méprisants à côté de notre libre de nove
à l'assiette
jean sur ça sur sa même de la partie
culturelle ça fait partie de la
politique culturelle parce que la
bibliothèque schoelcher c'est un
bâtiment
je dis oui j'ai donc cherché d'autres
questions côté à côté d'un seul yves y
avait notre livre écrit par le même
auteur alfred marie jeanne une traversée
verticale du siècle et l'auteur est
libre de mettre ses commentaires ses
deux adjectifs un dock
je tiens à dire et à rhode hommage au
personnel et à la direction de la
bibliothèque schoelcher qui a fait ce
travail et qui est l'objet d'attaqués
qui soit mais imerys à marie-hélène
mi-août nom reprend le cours alors on va
reprendre le votre programme quelles
sont les grandes actions que vous menez
parce que vous ne détienne politique
culturelle et on ne la voit pas oui on
ne la voit peut-être pas mais si on
prend la peine d'observer de suivre les
choses on va peut-être comprendre notre
politique culturelle
nous ne sommes pas dans l'adoration ne
sommes pas dans la duration de tel ou
tel personnage
nous sommes dans des méthodes
scientifiques nous sommes dans une
objectivité et nous sommes entrés de
coquelicots cotisé certain nombre
d'orientations que nous avons annoncées
dans le programme d'une grâce en bleu
que j'ai alors les choses oui mon cher
et ouaga nous sommes de dangereux car on
a tellement exactement les choses
avancent mais nous ne maîtrisons pas
toujours le timing c'est pourquoi je ne
veux pas faire d'annoncé démagogique
pour donner le jeune avant-centre du
bois je lui dis alors j'explique ça veut
dire quoi
on ne réalise pas un équipement
simplement en lançant des ordres de
faire je prends l'exemple du lycée
schoelcher cela fait dix ans que nous
avons voté la démolition reconstruction
du lycée schoelcher et nous sommes
entrés m nous permettre de commencer la
reconstruction
nous devons faire face aussi à des aléas
soient juridiques soient techniques
soient parfois politiques ou des
côtelettes financière des coquettes
administrative ce qui était potasse et
la volonté que nous avons à traiter le
problème
alors la qualité des réalisations oui
vous me parlez du conservatoire
pas à nous avions aussi dans les
orientations le laboratoire des musiques
traditionnelles
toujours rien l'office de la langue et
de la culture créoles toujours rien
alors je vais vous donner c'est donner
simplement sec exemple on qui sont en
train d'être réalisés en ce qui concerne
l'enseignement artistique je veux dire
en seulement ici qui n'ont pas conservé
trois ou écoles pour le moment en ce qui
concerne l'enseignement artistique et au
travail travail considérable qui est
déjà réalisé parce qu'il va aller faire
il fallait faire justement la synthèse
entre le projet de l'ex conseil général
qui était le conservatoire de musique et
le projet de l'ex conseil régional qui
étaient les grâces l'institut régional
des arts de la scène et du spectacle que
je souhaitais
non ça n'existe pas c'est un projet donc
il fallait faire la synthèse entre les
deux projets conseil général et conseil
régional
cette synthèse est fait et nous espérons
en 2018 pouvoir présenter ce projet à
l'assemblée quand sept projets phares
justement qui va dans le sens de notre
politique culturelle l'éducation
artistique l'enseignement artistique
c'est quelque chose de fondamental pour
affronter pour faire face aux
problématiques de nos sociétés modernes
donc ça c'est un exode l'enseignement
artistique je vais vous donner une autre
réalisation qui est en cours le musée du
père pêchu c'est depuis l'époque d'
alfred marie jeanne président du conseil
régional mes mains sur mon site c'était
déjà le suis déjà dans les tuyaux et
chansons déjà des trucs de dingue tu le
fais à peine à réaliser vous continuez
un thème de mesures nouvelles impulsée
par la ctm qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est ce
que je suis en train de vous demander à
l'eau le musée du père pêcheur nous
sommes entrés de sortir la collection du
sous-sol de dijon du siège de la ctn et
nous avons fixé un premier rendez vous
au cours du premier trimestre de l'année
2018 pour faire l'inauguration d'une
exposition temporaire
je vous ai dit qu'il ya des années on
doit contrer va enfin y en a marre on
sait très bien les choix que je vais
m'avancer
le festival de jazz vient de se terminer
est ce qu'il ya une vision globale pour
les festivals parce qu'il y en a
tellement
chaque commune quasiment à un festival
de jazz est ce qu'il ya une vision
globale global pour harmoniser tout cela
en un festival de jazz et l'atrium et
nous continuons simplement au niveau de
la cité m nous continuons à apporter
notre soutien à la création et à la
diffusion artistique nous n'avons jamais
cessé
c'était forfait en direction des
artistes des écrivains c'est parce que
cinéma parce qu'ils disent ignorer ce
qu'il disait justement du majesty seul
qu'il se servait laisser complètement
délaissé et qu'ils ne trouvent pas
d'accompagnement pour créer pour est
pour même exporter leurs oeuvres et pour
les voir même pour les joints ya pas de
se dire baisse de 2 salles de spectacle
qu'est ce que vous répondez à aux
artistes du sein alors cela fait 19 51
qu'il dit ça est dans tous les pays
c'est aussi difficile
regardez un grand pays comme les etats
unis beaucoup d'anti s'auto difficultés
je répète que nous n'avons jamais cessé
l'effort qui fait en direction des
ensuite des dentistes mais forcément
cela se fait en fonction du budget
est-ce que dont nous disposons est ce
que la santé la phrase qu'on louis
lefranc bien sûr bien sûr que je suis
consciente de cette souffrance et nous
faisons tout ce que nous pouvons mais
nous ne ne faut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'argent c'est faux simplement cet
argent il est ventilé autrement
conformément à nos orientations à noter
la collection fait pas partie de
des orientations de le budget culture le
budget culture et ventilés différemment
conformément à nos orientations à notre
politique culturelle notre politique
culturelle c'est quoi
nous voulons faire de la culture un
facteur de développement qui favorise
l'élévation de notre conscience
historique frantz fanon l'élévation de
notre conscience martiniquaise notre
patrimoine
l'élévation c'est vraiment de notre
conscience humaine parce que nous disons
que l'homme
il a besoin de spiritualité bien sûr
qu'il faut satisfaire les besoins
matériels mais il faut aussi satisfaire
les besoins spirituels ce qu'on appelle
les besoins de l'âme
simplement parce que c'est avec ça que
nous pouvons affronter je disais les
problématiques de nos sociétés modernes
pour que un jeune de 24 ans ne tue pas
un jeune de 22 ans pour une moto volée
nous ne sommes pas dans la consommation
immédiat est ce que la culture peut être
un moteur d'un vecteur de l'économie
martiniquaise par exemple où en est-on
du bureau de tournage pour les films et
le cinéma matinik peut être aussi une
industrie pourvoyeuse d'emplois
absolument nous allons signer au cours
de ce mois de décembre la convention
avec le cnc et nous sommes à la
recherche de quelqu'un pour me fais
prendre la charge du bureau d'accueil
des tournages
tout ceci est en cours je répète que
nous sommes en tiennent entre cocquerez
tease et un certain nombre de dossiers
qui font partie de nos orientations
culturelles dernière chose le 31
décembre
vous allez débloquer les fondus de
l'atrium du tropique atrium de la scène
nationale pour pour qu'y puis-je pour
que ça puisse fonctionner sur les trois
ans à venir on a quinze secondes mais
forcément tropez quatrième est là et
bien vivant d'accord marie-hélène les
otages je vous remercie excellente
journée à lausanne au programme
[Musique]